The Washington Post just exposed a bunch
of dietitian colleagues who are being
paid by junk food industry and yes we
definitely need to talk
[Music]
hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen today we're going to be
talking about this piping hot tea of a
Washington Post article called the food
industry pays influencer dietitians to
shape your eating habits those
journalists woke up and chose violence
with a headline like that but clearly
your girl has some pretty big thoughts
so I got my tea let's chat I've been
working full-time in media for 11 years
so I've been doing brand Partnerships
long before there was like any kind of
Playbook on how to do paid Partnerships
I was doing spokesperson work long
before there was any kind of like Tick
Tock or Instagram reels like but anyway
I basically fumbled my way through this
kind of content creator role at the
start of my career because it was a
really new phenomenon and there were no
influencers for teaching influencing or
blogs to read about blogging like
influencing did not even exist when I
started I was a blogger like do we even
say that anymore now if you work in the
space at all you are a a influencer
though FYI I actually do not like that
term I don't identify with it at all I
see myself first and foremost as a
dietitian who just so happens to
disseminate knowledge to the masses but
anyways I actually learned best
practices by calling my dietetic college
up on the phone basically every week so
I was asking them what can I do what
can't I do what can I say what can't I
say Etc and honestly even they weren't
100 sure because social media was just
starting to take off but anyway
obviously I'm sure like I mean I know
that mistakes were made in my early days
and when I was starting out I'm sure I
worked with a bunch of brands that I
definitely would not work with today so
for example when I was fresh at an
internship and I was really still
exploring what kind of dietitian I was
and what I believed in I'm pretty sure I
wrote a blog post in partnership with
Weight Watchers no would I touch that
today and unless it was ripping them
apart also I did a video several years
ago with MSG in partnership with
whatever commodity board makes MSG and
while I still agree with everything I
said in that video because it was
heavily researched on my part personally
and I scrutinized the
out of the messaging that I was given
today I probably wouldn't partner with
MSG and I don't think that MSG is
dangerous but I also don't think that
it's contributing greatly to public
health either so I took that video down
a while ago because it just no longer
aligns but yeah back when I was just
starting out I didn't have any kind of
representation I had no mentors so I was
probably a lot more sheepish when it
comes to like pushing back on brand
messaging the influencer marketing World
in itself was so green like I said it
didn't even exist so I don't think that
any of us had really figured out our
roles or expectations for influencers
and influencer agencies but anyways I am
definitely in a very different place a
decade later so today I have a team
about 12 people helping me with content
and watching my back I've worked with
the top media coaches I've got direct
contacts with YouTube and Tick Tock and
I have a lot more support to help
navigate this constant only changing
landscape so I have come a long way
since that little green newbie posting
blog posts and videos in exchange for
granola bars or like free movie passes
because granola bars are delicious and I
love me a good movie night but these
things don't pay my mortgage nor do they
pay my staff so that's just my back
story on my own Journey as a dietitian
working in the media but I now really
want to talk about this Washington Post
article and I have some big big thoughts
so buckle up so in short this article
focused on social media videos created
by specific colleagues of mine who had
partnered with maybe what we would
consider more controversial commodity
boards like American Beverage and the
Canadian sugar Institute the former
campaign focused on unpacking the whose
concerns about artificial sweeteners
like aspartame and the latter campaign
was really focused on neutralizing
Extreme fear-mongering around sweets and
sugar the funny thing is I am on board
with both of these messages I certainly
can't speak to all the content pieces
they reviewed or referenced but just
because something is sponsored by an
industry doesn't mean it's necessarily
lies even if they the industry itself is
kind of assessed so for example let's
look at this real by Kara harp street
she literally explained why the who
headlines were misleading and alarmist
considering what they actually meant
which was something that at the time a
lot of us science communicators did
including myself I basically said the
exact same thing and nobody fed me that
script because I was not sponsored to
say it the headlines in my opinion did
not represent the data and then this one
from Jen The dietitian who gave some
really great suggestions for parents on
how to manage Halloween candy with their
kids including letting their kids eat
whatever they want on day one and two
this again is literally the exact same
advice that I've given on my channel
because it's what Pediatric and family
dietitians know works best I scan
through the other posts that were
mentioned here and while there are a few
videos that maybe messaging wise
wouldn't be 100 on brand for me but
that's me dietitians are not some
homogeneous group of robots just
regurgitating the food guide we all have
our own approaches to interpreting and
communicating the evidence just because
I personally can't see myself partnering
with these commodity boards because
again they don't fit the screening
criteria that my team and I have very
carefully crafted for me I don't think
it's wrong to be paid to communicate an
evidence-based message that's on brand
like all these messages that I believe
in but you know who does not believe in
them this guy right here the lead author
Anna had O'Connor anahad is well known
for his investigative journalism related
to the role of Industry funded research
on sugar and the Obesity epidemic which
again explains why this story was
totally his beat and while he may be a
Yale graduate and taking down Big Sugar
maybe a special interest of his he
actually has no training or education in
nutrition at all and yet not only is he
pretty much exclusively writing about
health and wellness for media
Publications but he somehow is qualified
to write a whole book about the foods
you must eat and co-author another book
on weight loss again no qualifications
in the field I've also seen him
interviewed on podcasts and YouTube
about nutrition as if he is a nutrition
expert and interestingly he seems to
focus on nutrition messaging that is at
odds with most major authorities
recommendations and therefore is at odds
with most dietitians recommendations
that is from what I can see he seems to
to lean into a very restrictive like no
sugar full paleo hunter-gatherer kind of
carnivore leaning intermittent fasting
diet so again once I discovered this it
totally made sense as to why this whole
article focused on the dangers of sugar
and aspartame it totally made sense why
he called out a handful of female
dietitians who happened to be largely
anti-diet diet dietitians who were
sharing pretty neutral evidence-based
information what's kind of shady is he
was ripping into them for breaking down
the who's sensationalized headlines on
aspartame and yet on July 12th he
basically did the same thing like one of
his wapo articles shared the exact same
messages that my colleagues shared
interestingly I didn't see any kind of
disclosure on behalf of the journalists
related to his personal nutrition belief
system or the nutrition books that he's
authored that supports his approach
which again were written without
education in the field I mean I feel
like that would have been good to know
seeing as that may have played a role in
his interpretation of the crime of
course seeing a nutrition expert
suggests any amount of candy Halloween
may seem dangerous to a nutrition expert
who vehemently is against any or all
sweets but just really ironic that
there's such a double standard here
because lack of disclosure was his other
main point of criticism and I actually
agreed with him here the suggestion that
in some cases dietitians did not make it
super clear that their post were
sponsored or who their posts were
sponsored by was shocking to me you know
I've trained and coached hundreds of
dietitians on best practices for media
and brand work because again I have had
skin in this game before day one and
disclosure for dietitian content
creators is rule number one so to be
clear the dietitians did disclose by
stating sponsored or add in the
description but they either did not use
the paid partnership tool or they didn't
tag the commodity board that sponsored
it and again I agree this is not ideal
this is not being super transparent this
is definitely not my practice when I
work with Brands like I have been so
adamant about this when I do any kind of
colleague webinars or mentorships
because when other influencer or content
creator dietitians don't disclose it
hurts us all it leads people to not
trust us exhibit a the moment this
article came out people ran to my
aspartame Tick Tock video and asked is
this sponsored spoiler alert it was not
and there are videos posted from like
more alternative Wellness accounts where
the comments are definitively accusing
me of being in the post when it's like
girl did you read it because that is
defamatory slanderous spreading
misinformation and quite frankly not
fair even if you disagree with my
content as influencers themselves they
have a responsibility to be truthful and
fact-based or they are more at fault
than the RDS in this post but back to
the piece and the author you know I
really do have to wonder if this
journalist had something just against
our DS across the board because I know a
lot of RDS who are not named in this
article who did lengthy interviews with
the authors and none of them were
included possibly because it didn't help
this journalist's case I also know from
expertise that some Brands and commodity
boards like will push back when it comes
to using the paid partnership tool or
being super explicit about the actual
sponsor which in the case of aspartame
was American Beverage and yeah it's
still on us to push them back and say no
I want to be super transparent I cannot
tell you how hard I've had to push
Brands sometimes but the guy could have
also laid it into industry for their
role in being secretive or sus because
it's not a coincidence that all of these
creators disclosed the exact same way I
wonder why but anyways bottom line on
the article I do not believe that the
author fairly represented the intentions
or actions of my colleagues but I do
believe we should all be cautious
interpreting any of these kinds of
pieces as unbiased truth we all need to
be more critical consumers of what we
read but back to me for like a hot
minute because I can only speak with 100
certainty about how I work as an RD
working in the media so a huge part part
of my personal brand has been honesty
and transparency I can't speak for all
Rd content creators who are working with
Brands but that is huge for me so in the
spirit of transparency I'm going to tell
you exactly how things work behind the
scenes over here step one
typically my agent will get an email
from a brand or an agency and that email
will say something like hi we love Abby
we're a food or supplement company
whatever and we would love to sponsor
one of Abby's YouTube videos or a tick
tock Etc here's what we're looking for
you know I don't actually work with a
ton of commodity boards or Industries
even though there are some that I fully
believe in but they just don't come my
way very often anymore but again I would
be asking myself if the industry or
commodity helps Public Health in some
way but if it's a brand or product which
is usually what I work with I will look
at the company's consumer facing website
look at the ingredients look at the
claims read third party testing reports
by the way this is a really easy way for
me to suss out which supplements we work
with and don't work with because I only
work with companies that do third party
testing but anyway then I'll ask some
questions if I don't see what I need to
see and if anything seems off it's an
immediate no sometimes it's a really
fast no that starts basically with my
agent so any heavy weight loss related
apps or supplements or scales she'll
send it to me as like a courtesy slash a
laugh and are both kind of like did they
even bother to Google me and what I do
but anyways I would say the percentage
of offers that I get 80 to 90 of them
die right here that's how strict we are
but assuming it passes my sniff test I
ask for two basic things I want to try
the product or service and I want to
know what their talking points are
because sometimes a product may seem
totally fine and benign on paper but
when I see their messaging I'm like hell
no the testing part is self-explanatory
I have to like it or if it's not my
style because I have my own little
preferences too I have to think that it
could be something that would be helpful
for at least some subset of my audience
but the messaging can get a little
tricky so basically for brand campaigns
they send out a deck or a PowerPoint or
like a word doc with their key messages
and usually like a set of do's and
don'ts for things that you can or can't
legally say it is fully up to me now to
take those messages and to create a
piece of content that communicates them
while still being true to my voice and
ammo often times some of the messages I
see in the deck are no for me and as I
mentioned when I was young and green I
probably wasn't as bullish as I am now
about it but now I am never afraid to
completely change things Redline the
out of it and push back so for
example a lot of food or supplement
Brands will want me to say something
like other product is clean and you guys
know and I like that word so I say no or
if they told me that they wanted me to
say that product will help you detox
I'll be like no we know that's BS and
sometimes they maybe want me to make a
nutrition claim that I don't feel is
supported by enough high quality
evidence so I will skip that or I'll
suggest a claim that is supported by
evidence and sometimes we push back so
hard we just can't reach an agreement
and we just have to walk away and I know
that I am lucky to be in a position
where I can be super super selective
like this and have the confidence to
know my worth as a science communicator
but I have worked really hard to earn
your trust and it's ultimately worth so
much more to me than like a one-off ad
read then it comes to actually creating
the content so sometimes they have an
angle that they're hoping to go for like
back to school or like a specific
holiday but for the most part I hold all
creative control I pitch a handful of
Concepts that I think will work for me
and my audience and where it makes
thematic sense to include the brand and
then I write the script the Brand's job
is simply to approve the script I wrote
for legal and accuracy reasons and to
prove the video that I shot again for
legal and accuracy reasons but I'm never
letting a brand tell me what to say how
to say it or what the video is even
about and by the way this is why I
typically do like ad read Style on my
YouTube videos I don't want Brands to
have a say in the content that I put out
there for you guys like I'm really
really really strict about protecting my
IP so it's like they sponsored a video
but I'm still 100 in control and then it
comes to posting so we disclose both the
dang partnership actually I cannot tell
you how many times brands have pushed
back because I always like to put the
disclosure like A.D in the first
sentence the copy of the post because
that way you don't need to click see
more to understand and notice that it is
sponsored but a lot of the brands or
agencies that I've worked with will want
me to kind of put it at the very end
with all the other hashtags and so
that's what most influencers do but
according to the FTC and also just like
my basic morals I don't think that is a
clear transparent disclosure it needs to
be visible and while the paid
partnership tool is not mandatory I do
think it adds a visual on the video that
again helps people clearly understand
and see that it is a paid partnership
now the other thing I want to clarify
about us dietitian influencers working
with brands that I feel that the
Washington Post article misrepresented
is this idea that we're all just kind of
working with these Brands behind the
scenes to push some kind of sinister
agenda that like the more aspartame game
that gets consumed the more money we
make I mean there may be dietitians out
there who are long-time ambassadors or
spokespeople or Affiliates for a
commodity or brand which again they
should be legally disclosing every
single time that commodity or brand is
mentioned but that's not personally how
I work I mean maybe one day I'll sit on
the board for a brand in which case
again you will know about it every
single time they're mentioned but for me
each individual piece of content is
spelled out super carefully in our
contract so it's not just like I'm
always sneakily seeding messages in
without you knowing and I'm going to use
Dairy as an example because of all the
brands or industries that I've partnered
with dairy content is arguably the most
controversial so first of all While I
Work Dairy well I 100 appreciate that
Dairy is not for everyone whether it's
because you're vegan or lactose
intolerant or you just don't like it but
Dairy is a huge part of my family's diet
it's a major source of quality nutrition
for me and for many other there's a
plethora of quality unsponsored peer
review research to support it and the
messaging is always evidence based not
to mention me eating dairy and sharing
nutrition education about Dairy doesn't
mean I'm not eating and not sharing
nutrition education about non-dairy
Alternatives like look at my fridge I'm
an equal milk opportunist all of these
things can have their place and thinking
one is nutritious doesn't mean that
Alternatives that people depend on are
bad and that is really important here
like I never talk up a product by
putting an alternative down because
chances are I think both are really
great so this is very much on brand for
me and again I'm not getting like
monthly cash installments from the dairy
industry to brainwash my followers into
eating more cheese if I'm being paid by
Dairy to talk about Dairy on Instagram
you will know it if I'm being paid by a
cheese brand you'll know it I am being
paid on a per content piece basis for
that one random Tick Tock or that one
sponsor ad read on my YouTube channel so
I don't become richer if you eat more
yogurt there's literally no incentive
for me for you to buy Dairy over
non-dairy I actually don't even get any
information on Roi when I do a campaign
but anyway what I am saying is that if I
talk about Dairy and the video doesn't
say sponsored I'm not being paid for it
no one has looked at it and said yep
that looks good it's just what I'm
eating or doing or taking and if it says
sponsored I'm being paid for it I look
at the messaging I craft the content in
my voice based on what I'm comfortable
with and they gave it a thumbs up before
I post in both cases the messaging is
the same I like Dairy so I talk about it
both when I'm paid and when I'm not
being paid and again most of you guys
know I talk equally about non-dairy milk
Alternatives as well and know that if a
brand makes its way onto any of my
channels it has been heavily vetted
specifically by me so the bottom line is
I was really hurt by this article I felt
that the author went into it with a
clear agenda against female diet
petitions particularly anti-dye diet
dietitians because perhaps our general
messaging of balance doesn't align with
more extreme restrictive Fringe diet and
again this interest was never disclosed
I only know that because I had to do my
own sneaky sleuthing investigative
journalism after hours and I also
thought that the tone really undermined
a lot of the important work that us
female media dietitians do and shamed us
for seeking out any means to turn the
hard work that is science communication
into a career or side hustle it takes an
enormous amount of work to research and
write evidence-based nutrition content
like a YouTube script requires grad
school dissertation level work and I
post two 20-minute YouTube videos a week
two shorts a week seven tick tocks a
week three blog posts plus up to 14
Instagram posts and floor knows how many
stories this is a job and YouTube ad rev
isn't what it used to be if you want
really well researched well well written
content you have to be okay with
dietitians accepting sponsorships that
they feel represents their MO you do not
have to be okay with them being sneaky
about it and not disclosing nor should
any of us be spreading myths or
disinformation that could harm the
public but I don't know like diffusing
the panic over the media reports about
aspartame or telling parents that
restricting sugar to aggressively is bad
is not dangerous misinformation it's
exactly what I would tell people too
what I am saying here is that as
dietitians we need to work for your
trust and I know that I've worked really
really hard to earn yours transparency
honesty and evidence-based practice
that's what you've come to expect from
me and that is what you should continue
to expect from me but I would love to
hear your thoughts any questions any
clarifications I'm happy to go into more
detail leave me a comment below and
don't forget to hit my description for
my free Hunger crushing combo ebook and
I will see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]